the ACLU says it will go to federal
court today to push the government to
find and reunite families separated at
the border more quickly this new effort
comes one year after the Trump
administration announced its so-called
zero tolerance immigration policy which
ended last June the administration says
more than 2,700 children have been
reunited with their parents but some
families are still fighting to see their
children today
Manuel work has filed this report from
Arkansas where a father and son were
finally reunited after nearly a year
apart ten year-old Edwin Alva Suez has
been waiting 326 days for this moment
it's the first time he has seen and
hugged his dad Jose since they were
separated
[Music]
Jose says he and Arvind left Guatemala
last May after receiving death threats
from gangs they arrived in the u.s.
seeking asylum but Jose does not speak
English and told us while in ice custody
he signed a document in English that
ended up being his own deportation order
no one was explaining to you what you
were signing no no he told us Jose was
deported back to Guatemala and his son
Edwin was left in ice custody the
Department of Homeland Security says it
has identified nearly 3,000 children who
were affected by the Trump
administration's zero-tolerance policy
but the exact number of separations is
unknown since the government failed to
properly track every case for those
identified like elephant and Jose the
road to reunification is often long nice
to meet you
we met Irving a few hours before he was
reunited with his dad
you miss him a lot
Aaron was in the government's care for
five months before being released to an
uncle in Arkansas he was anxious to see
Jose again what are you gonna tell him
he's the best dad I knew loved him a lot
with the help of the nonprofit al otro
lado Jose was allowed back in the US
pending his Asylum hearing and within
days of that he was in an airport in
Arkansas holding his son after nearly a
year now what's it like to have him hold
you
he's the other half of your heart - for
CBS this morning
and while Bojorquez Rogers Arkansas
manis report is so incredibly important
instead of just reporting about policies
we have to report about the people that
this affects the cruelty how it tears
your heart apart to be a part of a child
and it's an important reminder that
there are still so many kids who are
still separated from their parents we
would not stand on that in that country
if you had a little boy a little girl
who you had not seen and had no idea
where they were we wouldn't stand for
that here yeah freaking to see at the
end of this policy is a little boy away
from his father